let T of T so capital T of lowercase T
denote the temperature capital T in
Windhoek Namibia measured in degrees
Celsius when it's T lowercase T hours
after midnight on a given day the table
below lists a few selected values of the
function alright when six hours after
midnight our temperature is 19 degrees
Celsius nine hours after midnight or
nine a.m. 25 degrees celcius 13 hours
after midnight which is the same thing
as 1 p.m. our temperature is 31 degrees
Celsius
when did the temperature increase faster
so this is between 6 & 9 a.m. so 6 & 9
a.m. 9 a.m. and 1 p.m. so that's between
these two points or did the temperature
increase at the same rate over both
intervals well if we want to figure out
the rate of increase the rate of
increase so let's see rate of
temperature change temperature change
well this is going to be equal to our
change in temperature capital T over our
change in time and this triangle that's
the Greek letter Delta it represents
change in so change in temperature over
change in time so let's think about how
this what this is what this rate of
temperature changes between these
different intervals so between 6:00 a.m.
and 9:00 a.m. so let me really in
temperature over change in time so what
was our change in temperature our
temperature went up by 6 degrees Celsius
6 degrees Celsius let me just write it
here 6 degrees Celsius and what is our
change in time our time went up by 3
hours plus 3 hours so you're going to
have a change of 6 degrees Celsius
positive change of 60 degree Celsius
over a positive change we've gone 3
hours into the future so for over 3
hours we increased our temperature by 6
degrees or you could say it's an average
rate of change of 6 divided by 3 is 2
degrees Celsius per hour notice I'm just
keeping the unit's the same degrees
Celsius per hour so that's the rate of
change between 6 a.m. and
9:00 a.m. now let's ask ourselves the
same question between 9:00 a.m. and 1:00
p.m. so our change in temperature over
change in time what is our change in
temperature
well our temperature goes up from 25 to
31 degrees Celsius that's another 6
degrees Celsius so that's another 6
degrees Celsius and but it's no longer 3
hours to go from nine hours after minute
to 13 hours after midnight we're now
doing it over 4 hours so plus 4 hours so
6 degrees Celsius over 4 hours and we
actually don't even have to calculate
you see that you've had you've had the
same change but you've had to do it over
more hours so this is a lower rate of
change the temperature is increasing
slower here it took it four hours to
increase 6 degrees Celsius well over
here it took it only 3 hours so
immediately you might recognize that
look this is going to be faster if you
increase 6 degrees Celsius over 3 hours
that's faster than increasing 6 degrees
Celsius over 4 hours but just to make
the comparison a little bit just to make
that compares it a little bit clearer
let's actually just do the math here 6
divided by 4 well that's going to be 1.5
1.5 and degrees Celsius per hour and
here you can make the direct comparison
to degrees Celsius per hour is faster
than 1.5 degrees celsius per hour so
that's why we liked we liked this choice
this choice up here